[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'univers que Jean-Christophe Granger a
créé dans dans son livre mis était très
clair au niveau de l'atmosphère au
niveau du feeling une gueule à faire des
conneries quand tu es tout
seul
[Musique]
mais je crois que toute façon il a un
truc naturel qui s'est fait ça fait
encore partie des premiers rôes qu'on
propose pu c'est encore un personnage un
peu écorché donc forcément trouve mon
compte le personnage de sec c'est un
personnage quand même très intéressant
c'était quand même un challenge pour lui
au départ mais j'ai tout de suite senti
qu'il en était complètement capable
juste si j'arrivais à bien le diriger et
à trouvé vraiment l'essence du
personnage interp et vous êtes le BRI il
y a pas de limite d'â dans la police
française j'adore faire des flics à la
retraite qui ne peuvent pas se détacher
de on peut pas seer de ce qui est unlic
ça a été vraiment génial parce qu'ils
sont vraiment inendus dès le départ en
fait ils sont très similaires a été
paternalisme très sain avec moi quoi
très très humble très très normal ça
donn vachement de force à ce qui se
passait quoi il y a eu cette relation un
peu de de
mentor apprentil quelque part qui s'est
fait naturellement et et je pense que le
film est très très singulier dans ce
sensl il est il est unique il a une
esthétique qui sort du
[Musique]
l'EOT